you said you know we're going to be
bringing out the resurrection right now
that was 2016. is it coming soon yeah
sooner now because it
it is such a massive uh undertaking that
you can't do it lightly and you can't do
it quickly you have to really consider
what it is that you need to show in
order to be poignant it can't be linear
you have to have many things to
juxtapose against one another even from
different time periods in order to
illustrate what something means in a
more full way and I think it's going to
be a real jigsaw puzzle to do and I have
two scripts right and and one of them is
very structured and a very strong script
and kind of more what you'd expect and
the other is like an acid trip and
because you're going into other Realms
and stuff okay I mean you're in hell
you're in you know you're it's it's like
you know you're watching the angels fall
oh wow it's like crazy you know is Jim
gonna come back as Jesus yeah of course